- [Group] Black lives
matter, black lives matter!
- [Group] No peace, prosecute the police!
- [Group] Black lives matter!
- Around the world, since this weekend,
there have been protests
that mixed sympathy
with the U.S. protesters
and anger at the U.S.
as well as anger over local issues
in places where people see
parallels to the situation
in the U.S. that minorities
are being repressed,
that police are restricting
gatherings, protests
with what they see as excessive violence.
- [Woman] It's just gut-wrenching,
the climate of what's
happening in America,
and it's also happening here in Australia
though it's subtle.
Racism is real for me.
(muffled group shouting)
- [Group] The people, we the people!
- In essence, the U.S.
protests have struck a chord
in many other countries around the world.
(dramatic mallet percussion music)
- [Man] Say his name!
- [Group] George Floyd!
- [Group] No justice,
no peace, no justice!
- [Group] Silence is betrayal!
Silence is betrayal!
(dramatic mallet percussion music)
- For many years, the U.S. has
been the world's moral voice
on so many of these issues.
When other countries have
called out the riot police,
started bashing heads,
using water cannons,
rubber bullets, tear gas,
the U.S. has been there
urging calm, wagging a finger.
Russia, China, in this
case, they get to say,
well, look, you're doing the
same thing, United States,
so you have no authority to criticize us
for doing exactly what you're doing.
(dramatic mallet percussion
and electronic music)
(Carrie speaking foreign language)
(muffled foreign language speech)
(Zhao speaking foreign language)
- The American people.
(dramatic electronic music)
The world has got hurt--
- [Dan] The situation
playing out in the U.S. now
is at a, probably at an emotional level,
fairly disturbing to much of the world.
To see the U.S. literally
in flames like this
and in conflict like this
has got to be traumatic.
(muffled group murmuring)
(gunfire popping)